the topics of free speech and censorship
are the top of minds of hundreds of
millions of people around the world
right now every time you go on the
internet you see somebody getting
censored d platform are you allowed to
say something are you not can you talk
about vaccines can you talk about mass
can you talk about inflation what is
going on on the internet now of course
every single platform they have a
different perspective on this some of
them have their own rules some of them
simply say we're going to follow the
laws and others try to put together
these external boards of fact checkers
and information specialists they're
going to determine what's right and okay
to say and what's not well where does
youtube stand on all of this well we
just got some new information the
youtube ceo had this to say about online
speech censorship and what they want to
see happen in the world our
recommendation if governments want to
have more control over online speech is
to to pass laws to have that be very
cleanly and clearly defined such that we
can implement it there are times that we
see the laws being implemented or being
suggested that they um they're not
necessarily clean or
possible for us to cleanly interpret
them um and we've also seen sometimes
there's laws passed just for the
internet as opposed to for all speech um
and i do think that's a dangerous area
when we start to get in and say oh sure
you could say something like this in a
magazine or on tv but you can't say it
on the internet
now here's what's interesting about her
perspective one i agree we shouldn't
have different rules for the internet
versus television magazines or in
private conversation if you're allowed
to say something you should be allowed
to say it in every venue not just in a
magazine or on television now of course
there's a big slippery slope here though
if all of a sudden the government is
coming in and telling you what you can
say and can't say there's a lot of
questions why are they drawing the line
in a certain place why is it that you
can't say certain things is it simply to
further their agenda or are they
actually trying to create some sort of
positive impact on society i personally
don't want the government to have more
and more reach over what we say on the
internet i don't think that we should
allow for the interpretation of those
rules by random employees at technology
companies that have the power to change
algorithms news feeds to de-platform
folks or prevent you from saying
something the true test of free speech
is actually protecting the speech of the
people you disagree with what we've seen
time and time again is that these
platforms and governments they simply
want to silence their critics they want
to silence the people that they don't
agree with the problem in the world is
that we don't know what truth is at all
times there used to be things that we
thought were wrong that now we all
believe and so if you don't allow for
speech you don't make progress in a
society
ultimately we should encourage the
competition of all ideas and almost all
speech
yes there are things that should be
looked at whether it's hate speech it's
the encouragement of violence or other
things that i think most people in
society agree on but the second that you
get into trying to determine
misinformation or truth i don't want my
government to be the arbiter of truth
and i don't want my social media
platforms to be the arbiter of truth
either ultimately what we have to do is
return to common sense but as we know
common sense isn't so common anymore to
hear the youtube ceo talk about this so
openly to encourage a government to get
more reach to get more control of online
conversation
scares the hell out of me i want to go
the other direction i want our
government to get the hell out of the
way i want our government to stop
worrying about what we're saying on the
internet as long as we're not causing
harm to other people as long as we're
not inciting violence as long as we're
not
committing hate speech everyone relax
humans for thousands of years have
figured out how to communicate with each
other they figured out how to organize
with each other and they figured out how
to improve the world we now live in the
safest most prosperous time in human
history trust the people
we'll figure it out
we don't need the government
or the social media corporations telling
us what we can say
when we can say it or who we can talk to